the picturesque setting of the Swat
Valley
in 2007 the army led a military
operation here to clear out the Taliban
almost a decade later behind the walls
of this former hotel soldiers are trying
to deter and D radicalize would-be
terrorists the fact that such a center
is still needed shows how hard the fight
against extremism is michelle has seen
over 1500 men come through its doors
since 2010 we were not allowed to
identify the current class they have
either been members of terrorist groups
or have helped jihadi fighters each
program lasts three months where the
students learn vocational skills and
attend basic religious classes the army
claims a success rate of 99% Muhammad
Ali was just 19 years old and a
university student when he was persuaded
to head to Hammond in Afghanistan he was
trained by the Taliban who threatened to
kill him when he tried to leave
authorities arrested Mohammed once he
came back to Pakistan
jihads real meaning is a person's
individual struggle but in their
language they said it means to kill
people or be killed yourself when I
heard this definition I thought it was
the truth according to Islam and this
inspired me I didn't have enough
knowledge about it at all Mohammed is
due for release soon and is convinced he
will not go back to his old life
Abu Muaz Posada if the handler comes to
me again I will tell him to leave me
alone because the meaning of jihad he
taught me is very different to the rail
jihad I have learned now and if he keeps
on bothering me I will tell the
authorities cook African that watching
the man aged from just 18 to over 70 and
the resident psychologist says they pose
multiple challenges
you social problem hotel hum cause those
who have social problems we give them
counselling we teach students with a low
IQ and give them tests and those who are
religious extremists we have scholars
who tell them the true meaning of a
famous religious scholar many of those
who join groups like the Taliban often
come from impoverished backgrounds but
many highly educated and affluent young
people have also been drawn to extremism
here and nearly all terrorist attacks
committed in Pakistan since 9/11 have
been carried out by someone under the
age of 30
60% of Pakistan's population is 24 or
younger expert suggests the crises in
education health and the economy
provide a ripe environment for
radicalization these students at
Peshawar University say they are often
frustrated we don't have a job market
here because of the law and order
situation people are not investing here
there was a lot of militancy in my area
and Haber agency so we somehow managed
to come here but most of my classmates
of the matrix they were radicalized and
now they have died our religion teaches
us to stay worldly and to stay in the
religious point of view and because
there is no balance some people are
ending and ending up in radicalization
and some people are over educated so
they turn into being non-religious and
the radicals turn into being extremists
the government says addressing the
complex issues that fuel terrorism
remain a priority but change will not
happen overnight security officials will
be closely monitoring Muhammad when he
is released though it will take years to
fully assess whether the centre's
attempts to D radicalize him have been
successful